the government will today set out its
plan to ban the distribution and sale of
plastic straws drink stirrers and cotton
buds of Environment Minister Therese
coffee
joins us now from Westminster Minister
lovely to see very good morning to you
and I suppose we should point out that
this is the start of the consultation
periods we have six weeks for the public
and other interested organizations to
make their views had but what exactly
are you proposing we're looking to phase
out the sale of these particular items
we have an overall target to try and
remove avoidable waste by 2025 when it
comes to plastics and this is a good
start we've already seen consumers make
the change we're starting to see
manufacturers make the change but we
think it's important to make sure that
unless people really need a plastic
straw or other things then we should
basically take them out of circulation
in this country yeah just to pick you up
and what you mentioned there that some
people that are actually good practical
uses for having plastic stores one of
our paper reviewers this morning at
pointing out the fact that actually for
some disabled people you know a plastic
stores an essential item that's right
and that's been at the forefront of our
thinking about how we support people
with disabilities or other medical needs
for plastic straws and that's why we
refer to that in our consultation today
as potential exemptions but the overall
reason why we're trying to do this is
unfortunately too much plastic gets into
our rivers and streams which ends up in
the oceans and that has a real problem
with marine wildlife and that's one of
the driving forces behind today I have
to say not that I spend most of my times
in bars and pubs but it is becoming
increasingly difficult to actually find
places which will just as a as a matter
of course offer you a straw with your
drink do we need to be so serious do we
need to to change the law rather than
simply try and persuade people to and
organizations to follow your lead I
think that we still need to take that
positive action I recognise people are
starting to make the habit change I've
been pushing on this for a year now
writing to leading pub companies to try
and get them to change you know dare I
say at one point in Westminster I was
known as the straw Snatcher simply be to
try and get people to recognize they
don't need these straws of course as I
say there are some exemptions so there's
still this challenge I think around the
country we're starting to see some other
retailers of
fast-food outlets starting to make that
change but this will give emphasis and
momentum to make sure that we come up
with the appropriate research to get
better straws for people that still need
them but also the other challenges of
simply saying do we really need to have
this plastic in our lifestyle the
answer's no we don't have this straw
snatch are you can bet your bottom
dollar I'm going to remember that for
our next interview Minister but just in
terms of the time scale and all of this
clearly there is a need for us to act as
quickly as possible
couldn't we get this done a bit earlier
than October 20 1912 2020 which seems to
be the proposal well I think that we
really want to hear very detailed
submissions particularly from those who
are seeking medical exemptions and other
kinds of exemptions that may be
necessary so we want to get this right
quite often we've got away from the
habit hopefully of rushing into
legislation which then doesn't work
properly I think this is a clear signal
of direction that we want to see an end
to plastic straws stirrers and cotton
buds but I think that it's appropriate
that we take the necessary time to get
the right legislation